[Music]
good morning John is Tuesday January
23rd if you're wondering why I'm blowing
on my line it's because its T what I
needed something that I could toast with
congratulations on your prince
nomination that wasn't exciting enough I
need to be more excited about that - the
Prince award to an abundance of
katherines
- Katherine's there's one sitting right
here she's what evening
dude silver medals - not quite doing as
good as you did the last time sorry
that was kind of mean so I was at a
bookstore today and the lady came up to
me and said you're John Green's brother
oho so it turns out I'm famous now well
she might very well be your biggest fan
she has a section in her book store
devoted entirely to you in fact there
are several sections in her book store
devoted entirely to you well they're all
kind of small she had heard that you won
the Prince prize I don't know what
you're gonna do with all the man you
just bracket him up what do you do with
- Prince Awards do you actually get a
thing do you get like a statue
already does you know every single one
of your books get a sticker on which
school I like the sticker I think the
sticker is good you just get more money
did it give you more money is there a
you know reward now there's something
that I wanted to talk to you about when
you receive the information that you
were getting the Printz award one of the
things that you did not do was your
happy dance is your happy dance actually
your happy dance are you just trying to
entertain us because if you're just
trying to entertain us and this thing
isn't real man and it has to be real or
you know it could be fake we can start
faking things and that might be
interesting for example I generally sit
by the fire with a glass of wine in my
girlfriend's coat girlfriend girlfriend
huh
yes go-go friends coach we are married
because this is fake time I'm lying
about things obviously so I was recently
at your friend Maureen Johnson's blog to
discuss a long conversation which you
and Johnson and Lockhart had concerning
the suffix in your pants it turns out
that every book title becomes better
when you add in your pants to the end of
the title I'm going to go around this
lovely Kevin and find books the dance of
the dissident daughter in your pants
present moment wonderful moment in your
pants stumbling on happiness in your
pants the left hand of darkness in your
pants the student Bible in your pants
yeah so I'll see you tomorrow
and I know that you don't personally
know this but Catherine's in your pants
is actually quite a nice thing I don't
know about an abundance of katherines I
promise I don't but one chapter in my
pants it's quite nice